[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLEMENS OERTEL:
Welcome, everyone.
Thank you for joining us today.
What we would like to
talk to you about today
is the initial steps of
our journey at the Imagia
to build a collaboration
ecosystem to help bring AI
to health care.
And right off the bat,
please allow me to say this
is my very first talk in public.
So if I seem nervous,
it is because I am.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.
May we do a quick initial survey
just to get a feeling for you
in the audience?
May I ask those in the audience
who work in health care
to quickly raise their hand?
Yeah, that's a good number.
And who of those are actually
involved in clinical research?
That's less.
And who is already deploying
AI systems in production?
Smaller.
And last question
in that direction,
who is using AI in
clinical research?
Congratulations.
And if we may ask one personal
question, who in the audience
knows someone who has
been affected by cancer?
That's a very large number.
So without further ado,
my name is Clemens Oertel
or, for the ones who know German
pronunciation, Clemens Oertel.
I have been working as a
program manager and software
architect at Imagia,
helping in its federations
and traceability efforts.
JONATHAN KANEVSKY:
Thanks, Clement.
CLEMENS OERTEL: Jonathan.
JONATHAN KANEVSKY:
Hi, everybody.
My name is Jonathan
Kanevsky, and I'm
a board-certified reconstructive
surgeon based here
in California.
And I've been leading
the team at Imagia
in the area of
clinical innovation.
So before we jump into our talk
on data, AI, and health care,
Clemens and I wanted
to share with you
some words from a
health care visionary
who really foreshadowed
the explosion
of big data in health.
Dr. Larry Weed, who
you see up there,
he coined the term
knowledge couplers.
He gave a famous grand rounds
lecture in the Massachusetts
General Hospital in
1960, and he believed
that there was no way that
doctors could possibly
manage all the data that
was related to a patient.
He's responsible for creating
today's concept of what
is a medical record.
And I just wanted
to share with you
what he had to say over 60 years
ago about big data and health
care.
LARRY WEED: What I'd like
to do is go at this problem
not from the point of
view of the record.
I mean, we really aren't
taking care of records.
We are taking care of people.
And we're trying to get across
the idea that this record
cannot be separated from
the caring of that patient.
This is not something the
practice of medicine over here
and the record over here.
This is the practice
of medicine.
It's intertwined with it.
It determines what you
do in the long run.
You're a victim of it or
you're a triumph because of it.
The human mind simply cannot
carry all the information about
all the patients in a
practice without error.
And so the--
JONATHAN KANEVSKY:
So you can see
that this idea that
big data in health
is really not
something that's novel.
But here we are today sitting
almost six years later
discussing it, and I think Dr.
Larry Weed would be completely
ecstatic to know that we're
making so much effort in health
care and AI.
So I'd like to tell you
a bit about my experience
and why I'm interested
in health AI
before I give you the background
of our company, Imagia.
My interest in the I
started during residency
where, as a surgical
resident, I was
exposed to a number of patients
who were really suffering
in the medical system--
in particular, one
patient, a young girl
who died of metastatic
breast cancer, who
had a tumor that was
completely missed
by a screening mammogram.
And I remember shortly
after she passed away,
I spent the evening poring
through her mammograms trying
to find a tumor that
just wasn't there,
thinking that there's
got to be some way
that the human eye
just isn't capturing
what's clinically there.
So I was lucky enough to meet
a team of computer scientists
at Imagia who were
working on these problems
and wanted to team
up and try and find
a way to bring AI solutions
that would actually
transform health care.
So Imagia was founded in 2015.
We're a company of
more than 40 employees,
and we have close ties to
the Montreal AI ecosystem.
We have a great relationship
with the Montreal Institute
for Learning Algorithms, one of
the largest groups of postdocs
doing research in AI in Canada.
And we have active collaboration
with over five hospitals
in North America and Europe.
So today, Clemens and I want to
share with you our big picture
mission.
We also want to share with
you some technical details as
to how we are building an
ecosystem that powers discovery
for clinical applications.
So how do we impact a
patient's journey with AI?
A good example that we are
focusing on is lung cancer.
From screening with
X-ray or low-dose CT
to later in the patient's
journey with diagnosis
and biopsy, then to treatment
with targeted chemotherapies,
and finally with surgery and
then the long road to recovery,
each step of the patient's
journey is important to us.
Creating an AI tool for
each step of the journey
leads to a
comprehensive care that
focuses on value-based outcomes
such as quality of life,
not just mortality.
The first step of
a patient's journey
in the long road of what
it means to be diagnosed
with lung cancer is screening.
Lung cancer is the leading
cause of cancer-related death.
Despite the best efforts made to
screen the general population--
mostly smokers-- many patients
with lung cancer do not smoke.
Where we want to
deliver the value of AI
is detecting patients
early, stage one disease,
where it's most easily treated.
Screening is usually
the beginning
of a patient journey
that is filled with fear,
many unknowns, and often
made worse by the fact
that many patients are diagnosed
with advanced-stage disease.
Being diagnosed with
late-stage disease
means you have almost 20 times
more likelihood of death.
So finding the disease
at an early stage
is the best way to
improve outcomes.
Once that lung
cancer is detected,
the process of
establishing a diagnosis
is often a long,
cumbersome process
followed by choosing
the right treatment.
So why is this process so
time-consuming and confusing?
Well, it's difficult to know.
Should all patients be given the
most expensive molecular tests
right away?
Should a patient be started
on first-line therapy
if they have
advanced-stage disease,
or should they be advanced to
targeted immunotherapy right
from the time of diagnosis?
So in today's paradigm,
there's really two ways
to establish a diagnosis.
It's either tissue biopsy, which
is the current gold standard,
or a liquid biopsy.
Tissue biopsies are when
a surgeon or an oncologist
will take a piece of tissue
and send to a pathologist.
It's often not as good
of a gold standard
as we would imagine because,
up to 40% of the time,
a repeat biopsy is needed
or the tissue that was taken
wasn't sent for the
right test to establish
the right diagnosis.
Up and coming is a technique
called liquid biopsy.
It's growing in popularity,
and what it entails
is taking and sampling
blood from a patient
and looking for bits of
tumor DNA that has shed--
much like a dog sheds hair.
But, as you can imagine, that
also has its own problems.
Just like there are dogs that
shed a lot of hair and dogs
that shed very little hair, not
all tumors shed DNA equally.
Up to 25% of these
cancers don't shed
DNA, which means a
liquid biopsy would fail.
So what's happening is
that, in many hospitals
and many clinical settings,
specialists-- pathologists,
oncologists, surgeons--
despite their best efforts
to communicate, they're
functioning in silos.
They're not interacting
as closely as they should.
And if we want to be successful
in treating patients,
we need to transcend
the silos and use
AI to accelerate diagnosis.
After establishing a
diagnosis, the next step
in a patient's journey
is optimizing treatment.
Precision medicine initiated
a revolution 15 years ago.
However, it's yet to create the
transformational change that
impacts patients
from day to day.
For example, there
are very few drugs
that target known gene
mutations for cancer,
and we still don't
have a good way
of selecting patients for
treatment for immunotherapy.
The majority of patients that
are diagnosed with cancer
will not have the option to
be treated with immunotherapy.
This is because
patients usually need
to fail a first or a second-line
treatment that is not
tumor specific before
their tumor is rebiopsied
to see if it can be targeted
by a specific immunotherapy.
Even when patients are put
on the right immunotherapy,
as much as 90% of those
patients will have tumors
that are resistant to the drug.
And that's because their
small cohorts of cancer cells
within that population
that are just resistant.
So with our platform,
what we hope to do
is empower physicians to
use AI to identify features
invisible to the eye that
could help guide patients
to the appropriate therapy and
avoid dangerous and expensive
biopsies and molecular tests.
One example of
where this plays is
in the area of deep radiomics.
So radiomics is
an evolving field
where we believe that there
is information captured
in an image that is just not
accessible to the human eye--
patterns that relate to
disease, for example.
Is there a specific
morphology to a tumor
that could indicate
its genetic status?
Could a lung cancer be
EGFR-positive just based
on its radiomic fingerprint?
Where this comes into
play is an immunotherapy.
So by show of hands,
who had lunch today?
Most people here, but some
people may have skipped lunch.
Some people may have
skipped breakfast.
But if I asked everybody
here to run a marathon,
everybody would
perform differently--
the same way if I was to give
an immunotherapy to everybody
who was able to take
that immunotherapy.
Their bodies would
react differently
because everybody's immune
system has a different makeup.
And in immunotherapy for cancer,
you need your immune system
to be primed appropriately to
combine with that immunotherapy
to target the cancer.
So this is why many
immunotherapy therapies
fail or have such a
varied range of results--
because we don't know the state
of somebody's immune system
as well as we should before
that immunotherapy is given.
This is where deep
radiomics can have an effect
and give insights where we
didn't have them before.
Can we train our AI
models on CTs or MRIs
combined with
pathology information
from immunohistochemistry
to identify
patient's immune status before
we give them immunotherapy
so we know when is the ideal
time to give an immunotherapy
to achieve the best result?
So finally, patients
have been screened.
They've been diagnosed.
Their treatment
has been delivered
in an optimal fashion.
But now begins a long
road to recovery.
Chemotherapy can leave
patients with heart problems,
gastrointestinal
issues, skin damage.
Radiotherapy causes
irreversible damage
to the skin and
the immune system.
If you think about it, we're
really living in an age
where people are
surviving their cancer,
but now suffering more from
the treatment of the cancer
than the disease itself.
Treating cancer is a noble
and monumental achievement,
but now we must also focus on
minimizing the morbidity that
comes with cancer.
To transform this
delivery of care,
we have to treat
beyond a given disease
and focus on developing
treatment strategies that
can minimize harm
to the patient based
on their unique
biological makeup.
As we build our
discovery platform
to power clinical adoption,
it's important to remember
just how imperfect the
medical training system is.
Information is
constantly evolving
in academic silos
around the world,
and the main medium for
sharing this information
is through publications
and journals.
As a doctor, I can
tell you it's nearly
impossible for a physician today
to remain accurately up to date
on the latest advances
in medical science,
and it's even more difficult to
actually employ these advances
into medical practice.
So building a
platform that makes
use of federated medical
data across a network
will bring us one step
closer to understanding some
of the randomness we observe.
So before we shift gears from
the medical to technical side
of the talk, I just
want to leave you
with this point, which is what
we're trying to build at Imagia
is an ecosystem where we
empower doctors to bring
their clinical expertise to
create clinical adoption,
and we bring AI expertise
to bring about discovery,
and ultimately together to make
AI that transforms health care.
So I'm going to pass the
mic over to Clemens now
to share with you a bit
of how this magic happens
and the technical details.
CLEMENS OERTEL: Thank
you very much, Jonathan.
So based on what
Jonathan just showed us,
we at Imagia believe
that AI tasks related
to clinical questions
are best formulated
by clinicians themselves.
However, most clinicians
are not AI experts,
and that is exactly
what we're trying
to enable the clinicians
to do with the platform
that we're currently building
as Imagia based on Google Cloud
Platform--
namely, to use AI in the
clinicians' discoveries
without having to know
about the details of AI.
Jonathan already mentioned a
few of the possible questions
in the clinical
field where AI might
come in handy, such
as, could be predict
the efficacy of a
certain treatment for one
particular patient--
not for a big statistical
base, but for one patient--
based on information that
has been acquired early
in the continuum of care?
Today, most of the time, we
have standard treatment plans.
We apply the most commonly
applicable treatment first,
and only if that
doesn't work do we go on
to the more advanced,
more costly treatments.
And this might make sense
from a cost perspective,
from a public
health perspective.
But for an individual
patient, this
might not be the best approach.
Also, could be
determined the malignancy
of a tumor just based
on early imaging,
such as the EGFR
status of a tumor?
This way, a clinician could
choose the right treatment
early on.
Or, to express it
more generally,
can we predict patient outcome
based on raw data acquired
early in the continuum of care?
To answer these
questions, one usually
conducts a retrospective
clinical study.
And to give you a little
bit of a background,
to conduct such a
study the first step
is normally to build a
patient cohort for that study
and for that outcome.
To build a patient cohort means
to find suitable patients based
on past diagnostic or treatment
results, such as a drug worked
or did not work, tumor
was malignant or benign.
And that usually involves
going through vast amounts
of clinical records--
textual records.
This is actually
clinicians sitting
there sifting through
these records,
finding the right records,
the right patients
because these records
are not structured
for that kind of questioning.
And that's a tedious,
laborsome task.
And one of the
toolkit or tooling
that we had Imagia
developed to assist in this
is, based on NLP
and active learning,
a clinician can just
tag a few reports.
We then can go through
all the records
that there are, find
the best matches
based on these early
selections, and this
may build up a larger cohort.
And of course,
unfortunately, this
has to be happening
on premise because we
do need access to the full
data corpus at the hospital.
The next step,
just as difficult,
is to find the corresponding
imaging data because remember,
we want to be able to, based
on very early imaging that
was acquired before
we even knew what's
happening to that patient, to
make a prediction about a very
late outcome.
And unfortunately, as
Jonathan already pointed out,
this data lives in
different silos.
To connect that data
is not a trivial task.
And this is another
step where AI
can help us to find for
a given set of patients
the corresponding data for
an outcome in question.
And one thing we hope
to come out of this
is that, instead of running on
dozens or hundreds of patients
per clinical study, we
can actually scale this up
to thousands of
patients and beyond.
Overall, this is going from
patient-structured data
really to outcome-structured
data, which
is just the way how data is not
organized in hospitals right
now.
But now, this is where it starts
getting really interesting
because, once we have
this patient cohort
and this overall overview here--
what we're doing is we're
sending this data to the cloud
component of our platform, which
we're building on Google Cloud
Platform.
And here, we run an automated,
large-scale biomarker discovery
process to find
evidence for signals
in that data that correlates
with the outcome in question.
The goal at this
time is not to find
a highly accurate classifier
just yet, but really
to provide statistical
validation of that evidence
for such a signal.
And this discovery
process is entirely
driven by the clinician.
There is no AI expertise
involved at that time.
And this allows the
clinician to undergo
this as an iterative process.
For example, you
might try at first
to predict an outcome based
on the low-dose CT that
was very early taken,
but it might turn out
that in the low-dose
CT you just don't
have this kind of information
that you're looking for.
And this way, you can very
easily do another iteration
where you don't bring in
CTs that were taken later
in the continuum of care.
Once we have sufficiently
satisfied that we
have such evidence
in our data, this
is where the collaborative
aspect of our platform
can kick in.
Namely, we can collaborate
with other clinicians
from different hospitals
to enlarge the patient base
to make sure more subpopulations
are covered more thoroughly.
And we can collaborate with
AI researchers, AI experts,
to start looking into building
a highly-optimized classifier
for that biomarker, detector
for the biomarker in question.
And once this has
been accomplished--
and this is a part that is a
little bit beyond the scope
of this talk--
productization process can be
undergone to really produce
a clinically-created
biomarker in the end that
can truly affect patient care.
So if you allow me to
go a little bit more
into detail how this
discovery process looks like.
So as Jonathan
already said, it's
based on recent advancements in
a field called radiomics, where
the idea is to use
image features which
are hidden to the human
eye to directly deduce
a patient outcome.
To do that, we bring the imaging
data together with the outcome
information into Google Cloud.
Here as an example, we have an
image of a presegmented liver,
but this really is
just a representation
of a bigger patient data set.
And afterwards, we
apply a suite of
pre-trained, independent
feature extractors to that data.
Possible examples
here for these feature
extractors, just to give you an
idea, as those could be models
that look for a blob
with a fussy context
or a blob into which a
lot of lines lead into.
But all of these
feature extractors,
they are not outcome specific.
They can be used for
any kind of outcome.
And there, we have
thousands of them
that we all apply--
every feature extractor
to every single item
in the input data.
And each feature extractor
will present us afterwards
with an individual result.
We have a colorful map here
to showcase a little bit better.
But in the end, those
are just numeric values
on a continuous scale.
All of these results
are then aggregated,
and this allows us to
find the set of features
which best correlates with
the outcome in question.
And this set of features would
be our preliminary biomarker.
And just to reiterate,
the goal is really here
to look for the
evidence of such signals
corresponding to the features,
not necessarily the best
possible accuracy at that time.
Just to give it a little bit
of a technical twist, how
we implemented that
on Google Cloud,
we upload the data into
Google Cloud Storage.
We do run a frontend
in the front
based on Kubernetes engine,
which then sends all this data
into this multitude of either
sort of TensorFlow models
or extractors of other kinds for
which we could use Kubernetes
Engine or Cloud Functions.
The idea here really is to
make use of the scalability
that we get out of this.
So have on-demand scalability to
run this amount of computation.
And for the results,
then we utilize
BitQuery to run our analysis
and present the result back
to the clinician.
Now, when we're talking about
feature extractors and models,
et cetera in the
clinical context,
there are a few peculiarities
about medical data
that one really needs
to be aware about.
It is different data.
First of all, we have
highly imbalanced data sets.
That means we're looking for
a needle in the haystack.
So Jonathan mentions the
example of screening,
where we're looking
for a few patients who
are affected by a disease in a
population of very, very many.
And this gets even
worse for rare diseases.
Also, what we're
trying to predict
is potential treatment
efficacy for people
for whom the standard
treatment would not work.
So those are rather
the rare cases.
Also, we are dealing with very
tiny lesions in large data.
So for example, say examples
of pulmonary embolism,
there's one there, one there.
Honestly, this is
a few gray pics
in a bunch of a lot
more gray pixels.
That's not an easy one to find.
And to make matters
worse, this data
tends to be not two, but
three- or four-dimensional
for longitudinal studies.
So a lot of the standard machine
learning pre-processing steps,
such as scaling down
your data, it just
won't work because you pretty
much lose all the information.
To make matters worse, we have a
lot of variability in our data.
Certain features,
certain contexts
can manifest itself
differently depending
on age, ethnicity, gender,
genotype, but also anamnesis
of a patient.
For example, we are
talking about trying
to find the non-smokers
in a screening process.
But if we train our model
primarily with smokers,
most of them might exhibit
certain secondary symptoms
such as emphysema.
So we have to make sure
that our model doesn't just
pick up on the emphysema,
but really goes
for what we are looking for.
And there are a lot of
device-specific artifacts
in these images.
So what we see here, this is not
how an imaging modality really
acquires an image.
In the case of an MRI, we
are dealing with disturbances
in the magnetic field.
This is just the
visual representation
for human consumption.
The process of going from
the real physical data
to the visual data, this
is manufacturer-specific,
and those are artifacts
that we need to account for.
Luckily, we are not
left without tools.
So we very often deploy a
mechanism called curriculum
learning, for example,
to deal with tiny lesions
or imbalanced data.
The idea behind
curriculum learning
is that you really
start with a model that
trains on a very small subset,
on a patch of the data.
And then, as the
model learns this,
we continuously
increase the amount
of data, the amount of context
that be present to the model.
It works just as well
for imbalanced data sets.
You can start with a
rather balanced data set
and then go to
imbalanced bit by bit.
To account for the variability
and render specific artifacts,
we just have to have
enough data to have
sufficient representation of all
these problems in our data set.
But what I'm trying to
get it is that we're
dealing with a lot of data,
and we're dealing with models
that are deep, that are complex,
that need a long time to learn.
And this was one of
the reasons for us
to go onto Google Cloud with
this problem because here,
of course, we can make
use of the near infinite
amount of resources.
And especially for us,
TensorFlow, ML Engine, TPUs,
this whole stack
works really well
to address the
complexity of our models
because we get both the data
parallelism and the model
parallelism with
reasonably low effort.
Now, when I was talking about
feature extractors which
are used by clinicians for
this discovery process,
I mentioned that they are
pre-trained models, which
of course raises the question,
how are these models trained?
How are they built?
How can AI experts
collaborate with clinicians
to build such
feature extractors?
And this is one of the use cases
for our proprietary platform,
which we call Evidens.
A bit of additional information.
When working with
clinical data, as I'm sure
all of you who work
in health care know,
working with clinical
data is highly regulated.
Some of the regulatory
frameworks are HIPAA, now GDPR.
Health Canada has their own.
And I don't want to give
an exhaustive overview--
I can not give legal advice--
but what it boils down
to for us is this.
First of all, we of course
have to anonymize the data.
HIPAA, for example,
provides a list
of fields that needs to
be removed before data can
leave the hospital's premises.
And we need to apply
deanonymization,
deidentification
of the data, which
means assigning
random identifiers
rather than using the original
hospital-generated ones.
But it does it does
not stop there.
Data for clinical
research can only
be used based on patient consent
and institutional approval.
There are IRB ERBs.
That stands for Institutional
or Ethics Review Board
depending on where one lives.
And they grant ethics
approval for clinical studies.
The problem with this
consent and those approvals
is that they can be revoked.
So a patient could
walk into a hospital
and say, yeah, I
have past consent
for this technical study,
but I changed my mind.
And in the case of
such a revocation,
we have to be able to
delete the patient's data,
but also, to be on the safe
side, any kind of derived data.
This can be something simple,
such as I had a CT scan
and I cropped it
and saved this crop.
But this could also be
something more complicated,
especially in the
context of machine
learning where models are
represented by weights.
Weights are affected by
the patient's data that
went into the training process.
Now, if we are thinking about
models such as autoencoders
and generative models, it's hard
to guarantee that there is not
some detailed information
about that patient
inside the model that
would allow to regenerate
the patient's data.
So to be on the
safe side, we said
we even want to delete those
weights in the case of such
a revocation.
Of course, being
able to revoke means
we have to actually trace all
of this in the first place.
We have to make sure we know
for every single patient what
happened to his or
her data in the cloud.
And this does not
just mean the data
once it gets uploaded, but
also any subsequent processing
step that we might
apply to the data.
And to give a fairly high-level
overview of how we achieve this
in GCP--
there we go-- we upload data
from hospitals into the cloud.
We run a data ingestion
process, which brings that data
into a date lake.
But before any kind of
operation is happening
on a piece of data,
we always make
sure we create a trace log
entry that records for which
patient what data has
been done what to.
Any kind of data processing that
we run in the cloud we first
create a dedicated data set for,
which means we create a Google
Cloud Storage bucket into which
we copy data out of our data
lake to make sure
no single process
can ever access this data.
This is really a
highly-secure data storage
that nobody has access to.
For every process, we
create a dedicated data set,
and this is something for
us very easy to trace.
And it's just easy to show
that this works reliably
because only what goes
into this data set
can be accessed by the
data processing step.
Data processing, this
could be image processing,
model training,
anything like this.
Any kind of output produced
by a data processing
step, such as crop
images or model weights,
go in a Google
Cloud Storage bucket
which has been specifically
created for that operation--
which, again in itself, is link
back to all of the input data
and sufficiently traced.
So we have really a
traceability chain
from every bit of patient data
throughout our entire system
to any kind of
result that we store.
If you allow me to
go a little bit more
into detail on the first
piece of this puzzle, the data
ingestion, the first
step happens on premise
where we receive
a cohort and then
we upload it into our inbox,
which is hospital specific.
We can make use of
a service account
such is specific
to the hospital.
So only this hospital
has access to this inbox.
We have an ingestion process
which then copies the data
into our data lake
only after making sure
that the proper trace log
entries are being created.
One thing that we
also did to the inbox
is we created all
the deletion rules
because, when a patient
revocation request comes in,
you have a certain
amount of time
to comply with that request.
And we really tried to build and
robustness from the beginning.
So what if this
ingestor doesn't run
and the data just sits in the
inbox bucket as an orphan?
If a patient revocation
request came in,
this data would still exist.
We would have a problem.
So we just delete this
data after a couple of days
automatically.
But now, to the real
meat of the matter.
How can our AI researchers
use our platform
for their everyday work?
And our goal here was to
give maximum flexibility
to AI researchers.
And often, that involves running
not just single trainings,
but long workflows
with multiple stages
and conditional steps of
pre-processing, training,
analysis, visualization,
et cetera.
So we want to enable
researchers to do this while
still maintaining full
control over the data
and ensuring traceability.
And the overall idea for us was
we don't have the mountain come
to the prophet, but the
prophet to the mountain, which
means we have a secured area
where all the data storage
and execution is happening.
And in any kind of processing
step via the training data,
free processing is encapsulated
as a container or zip
file containing ML
Engine code and then
submitted along with a
query into our system where
we run this query
on the data service
and produce a data packet,
which I mentioned before,
which is given to the training.
The training runs on that data
and produces all the output
in an output packet,
which can then
be reingested for subsequent
use by later stages
in that workflow.
And again, one of
the important things
is that each one of these
steps, each one of these arrows
leads to according entries in
our trace log-- which means,
even for this device data that
gets reingested into the data,
we always know which original
patient that came from.
A few other Google
techniques that we use
is we have a per
training or per process
service accounts, which are
the only ones then allowed
to access this bucket.
This way, we can really make
sure that every training can
only access the data
it's supposed to,
but at the same time that
every bit of data we have
can only be accessed
by the training that's
supposed to access the data.
And by linking every
data along this way
back to the original
individual patient
data and the patient
identifier, we
can maintain that
requirement of traceability.
Starting to go a
little bit faster
because I'm noticing
we're running a little bit
short on time.
We the on top of this, to
make it really easy to use,
created a lot of
CLIs and frontends
and function as a service
and Cloud Functions
to model of these workflows.
And one example I
wanted to give is
we have one project which
involves colonoscopy,
where we receive colonoscopy
videos from which
we have to extract frames.
These frames have
to be prepared.
We have to identify
the type of lighting
that was used, for which we
have our own models to do this.
Then there is some manual
tagging involved by clinicians.
And only after
all of this can we
actually start building
cohorts because only then
do we know what
we're dealing with.
So then, we can build
cohorts and then
feed this into training.
And each one of these steps
undergoes this full loop.
So that final model that
comes out of this training,
we can still trace back
to every single video that
might have affected that model.
And of course, the
reason why we're
going through all this hassle
is to ensure revocability.
And as I said before,
a patient might
walk any day into the hospital
and say, I gave your consent,
but I changed my mind.
I want you to undo this.
It has to happen on premise
because we have to look up
the deidentified identifier.
But the important
piece is really
we sent this request
into the cloud
where we run this process that
we call nomen est omen revoker.
And this process can then
use all this information
that we previously
stored in the trace log
to identify every single
location of related data
to that patient in
be it our data lake
indices, any kind of bucket
running trainings, metadata.
Anything can be deleted--
will be deleted, sorry--
and a report will be
generated, which is then
sent back to the hospital.
And that's just one
of the requirements
that we have to have this
full loop from the on
premise through the cloud
back to the hospital.
Now, bridging back to the
biomarker discovery process,
of course all these
feature extractors
that we mentioned before are
models that have been trained
through this platform.
Those are models that are
deployed, that run somewhere,
that are used for the
biomarker discovery process.
In the case of
such a revocation,
what this allows us to do
is to automatically retrain
the affected models
just in this case
without the data
of that one patient
that just issued a
revocation request.
We can retrain
these models, making
sure all accuracy requirements
for every possible
subpopulation was
still being met,
and then automatically redeploy
this model, and this way
of ensuring a continuous service
for our biomarker discovery
platform.
So this is where we are today.
Ongoing work that we're
currently pursuing
is that we really want to
improve the trustability
of our platform.
We want to make it
easy for patients
to trust the platform
that we're building
to make people comfortable
when they contribute
to clinical studies.
Of course, one obvious thing
no talk in this time and age
can lift without
mentioning blockchain
is to use blockchain.
And one of the areas where
we think it could really
be beneficial is to use
blockchain's capabilities
as an immutable ledger,
where we can issue receipts
to patients and hospitals saying
yes, we've received this data
or we've received the
revocation request.
And there would be
no way to wriggle out
of that responsibility
that comes
with this data or that
revocation request.
In the end, is it the
solution to all our problems?
Probably not.
And if anybody in the
audience has any ideas,
I would love to talk
about that after the talk.
I don't know how to model
deletion with blockchain.
How do I guarantee that
something has been deleted
and there's no copy
anywhere left of it?
So there's always a component
of trust left in such a system.
You have to trust a system or
you have to trust a company
or you have to trust
a regulator or you
have to trust a
blockchain implementation.
A fully trustless system?
No, but we can really
try to improve trust
for patients and hospitals.
We are also looking
into implementing
certain cryptographic
guarantees, proxy
via encryption, to be able to
say we can use cryptography
to guarantee that only
certain processes can access
the data that they are
supposed to access.
And one next step
of that could be
this could allow us to
be really further patient
engagement by modeling
that process of consent
through cryptographic
guarantees, where a patient--
by re-encrypting keys specific
to a certain clinical study
or training to be done--
with their own key could
explicitly give their consent
to that clinical study.
We've been talking a lot about
data and in the context of data
mainly about patient data,
but there's more to it.
All of these consents
and authorizations,
they have data associated
with themselves.
Those are forms, processes,
and we would like to model this
as well to really
be able to give
a holistic end-to-end of
the different processes that
are involved on clinical sites
with respect traceability,
data in the cloud,
and revocability.
And we believe that there
are certain areas where
the centralized
learning in the cloud
might not be as suitable
or even impossible.
For example, if you want to run
a machine learning operation
on data that requires
information that otherwise gets
removed through the
anonymization process,
it's almost not possible
to run this in the cloud.
So for these few
cases, we are looking
into federated learning, where
data could stay on premise
and we only keep the
control in the cloud.
But of course, this is a
less desirable approach just
to do the hardware maintenance
and all of these headaches.
Back to Jonathan.
JONATHAN KANEVSKY: So I'm pretty
sure if Dr. Larry Reed was
to time travel from
the '60s, his head
would spin with the
complexity of how important it
is to think about some of the
things we're thinking about.
But ultimately,
to summarize, what
we've wanted to share with
you is our approach to create
this collaboration ecosystem--
which is powered by
the Google Cloud--
where we bring together
health experts,
engineering experts in a
way where they can not only
use AI without
the health experts
can use AI without
the knowledge of AI,
but to do so on a
large impactful scale
across a large network.
So thank you very
much for your time,
and we'd be happy to
take any questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]